I got into a fight with a cheese grater
welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid so I'd like to talk to you about
what is easily the most misunderstood
idea in introductory science entropy
isn't entropy just like energy or
momentum I mean they're all pretty
abstract yeah
first glance it kind of seems like any
other weird thing we'd measure so it's
kind of unclear why we misunderstand it
as with most misunderstood concepts in
science the problem is very subtle in
the early 1800s there were these nagging
holes and our understanding of heat and
temperature in fact back then it wasn't
even called heat they thought it was a
magical fluid that flowed between
objects and they called it caloric which
is the origin of the word calorie the
unit of energy used on food labels
remember at that time we had no
knowledge of things like atoms finally
in 1865 the term entropy was coined by a
german physicist named Rudolf Clausius
according to the online etymology
dictionary the word entropy means in
turning the Clausius was going for
something more like inside
transformation and he made it sound like
energy on purpose bastard that same year
he wrote the first modern form of the
second law of thermodynamics which says
the entropy of the universe tends toward
a maximum in other words as long as
you're considering everything the
entropy always increases keep in mind
this principle can be extended to
containers smaller than the universe as
long as those containers can be
considered unaffected by their
surroundings it wasn't until we
discovered atoms and began modeling them
in the early 1900's that we truly began
to understand what entropy was it's not
difficult to understand why the water in
this container has energy if you
consider all its little parts superzoom
every one of these molecules has energy
because they're zipping around they
wiggle and they nudge each other if we
add up all the energy of all the
molecules we just get the total energy
of the water there's nothing extra and
nothing missing we can't make sense of
entropy this way because individual
molecules do not possess entropy yet the
entire container of water does so where
the heck does it come from it's a
reasonable question entropy is actually
something we call an emergent property
which is a property that arises when the
whole is more than
some of its parts you are an emergent
property entropy though is something
we're inherently aware of even if we
don't realize it let's say you see
something like this it would be very
natural for you to conclude two things
one the coloring will spread until it's
uniform throughout the water and two the
coloring was added to the water right
about here if you run this process in
Reverse you can tell instantly that it's
going in Reverse simply based on your
personal experience in similar
situations the entropy would be
decreasing which would violate the
second law of thermodynamics however if
we take a closer look again superzoom
here are two water molecules colliding
inside the container looks just fine now
here's that same collision in Reverse
well there's nothing wrong with that
either
entropy seems to just emerge when there
are enough of those molecules in one
place for statistics to become important
okay so what is it there are a few ways
to understand what entropy actually is
but all of them involve analogies an
old-school definition is that entropy
measures the disorder of the energy of a
collection of particles let's say we're
going to drop a rock from this cliff at
the beginning the energy is all nice and
collected inside the rock by the time
the rock gets to the bottom the energy
has spread out into the air and into the
ground leaving only some of its still
inside the rock you can literally see
the increase in disorder of the energy
but the word disorder can be very
subjective and we have to be very
careful in science we strive for
objectivity sometimes we fail at it but
we try we have something to help us with
this problem called the messy room
analogy assume for a moment the items in
the following rooms represent the energy
not the particles the energy there's a
difference this room looks pretty
organized so by analogy we say low
entropy and this room looks pretty
chaotic by analogy we can say high
entropy but are you sure this really
depends on who lives in the room if you
ask the owner for something specific
like a t-shirt and they tell you it
would take a search party then sure it's
chaotic but what if they respond by
walking immediately to a pile of clothes
and pick up the shirt that's what we
might call organized chaos if they know
where everything is then the room is
still technically organized the same
goes for the energy in that cliff
example it's not disordered because it's
all over it's disordered because the
universe itself has lost track of the
Energy's origins
picture might have the same number of
dots as this picture but there is no way
to know if they're the same dots maybe
it was these or these or even these
thanks a lot entropy it's like the
universe has a witness protection
program for its energy and we call that
entropy so which kind of room is your
bedroom let us know in the comments and
until next time remember it's okay to be
a little crazy if you want to wear a
cool shirt like this or maybe like these
they're available at Science Asylum
Spreadshirt calm for the lazy people
there's an annotation over there there's
also a permanent link in the channels
banner if you want to check it out later
you know no pressure or anything
click it